right now though let's dive into the
trends of the market Geoffrey de Graaff
is truly exquisite at looking at charts
what they do say and also what the
charts don't say of course with
Renaissance macro what are the charts
not say right now in the market overall
market overall the church say do not be
a intermediate-term bear do not be short
this market if we look at the
performance of breakdowns breakouts
without question this is a market that
does have some momentum and it's good
the other part of that would be be very
careful on the reversion trade you know
we've had this big reversion and if you
look at the momentum versus anti
momentum trade over the last quarter
we've stretched this into the 95th
percentile in other words malarious like
that we've way extended into what you've
extended into a realm where the
performance of laggards doing well has
not consistently persisted and so in
other words it's a point where is really
the leaders are lagging and so it's the
point where that should start to reverse
out okay what does that mean for the
consumer discretionary Colgate's of the
world that McDonald's of the world their
way out extended their extended but
they've actually come in a little bit on
a relative basis over the last call it
two months and so this consolidation
that we've seen looks pretty interesting
to us Philip Morris McDonald's yeah
those those names look like they're good
solid trends the relative performance is
softened a little bit but again those
were leadership names in the februari
lows and they've come back how do you
interpret Apple Computer I mean we had
to chart up earlier an hour ago with
Michael holla were making jokes about
when Hans sold of course he's been a
uber bear on Apple technically what do
you do with in the the silliness of the
day-to-day emotion of the media on Apple
you have to follow trend I mean it's
that simple you use some trend
discipline and I don't care if that's a
65 day high if it's a 50-day about the
200-day moving average follow some trend
discipline and that's going to keep you
on the right side of Apple for the
entire decade levani that one moment
there with Jeff DeGraff was with
watching surveillance all week that is
the quickest way not to lose money is
just what mr. de Graaff said well I know
that you know the macro I can all make
fun you know
mentals are not what you look at but
what about something like Greg's that
are a Fed rate hike I mean surely they
could disrupt trends well they can but I
think when you're you know I worry more
about the unforeseen the 911s right I
mean when we talk about brexit you know
it's all slowly but surely getting built
into the system in one way or another
it's being handicapped now that doesn't
that's not to say that the mark is going
to get it completely right but it's not
going to be caught totally off-guard the
chances are that it's not gonna be
totally off guard when something like
that takes place because there is a
transition as karl was saying from one
equilibrium to the other so you walk in
the office of high frequency economics
you've got a brief one of the great
international economist of the world
what's the one chart you want to show
Carl Weinberg right now the one chart i
want to show carl war dollar cool i
would say gold go stay buckled well
Gold's trend and momentum change for the
first time in four years in January and
it really was one of those standout
moments for us we go through hundreds of
charts on a weekend it was one of those
standout moments for us it just said
something is different here than what
we've seen understand today to 13 03 10
now keeps rising look at silver right
and then you know compare that to the
industrial metals gold versus the
industrial metals has absolutely
trounced that relationship which is you
know historically that's not great news
for the economy it just says that
there's some disruption that's taking
place globally Carl what do you think
about the Nikkei lighting the Nikkei the
nikkei is a yen story and so the yen
strength is just absolutely an asthma
for the than EK in our view